実家でいいですあじゃあ確りはい今月はずの社長です
今実家に帰っております
もう全員集結いますとでみんなご飯食べてるんですけどやっぱね家だと動画取りづらい
ですね数がいる時使っちゃうんでなかなか行動が取れないんで共通の間待って下さった
子だった
あああ動画を取り札環境下に置かれているんですけどもうなんかねやっぱり実家って
いうのは面白いもので北へと進んでいる家にはない何かがあったりするんですよね
いろんな映画
縫いがありがてことにちょっと僕の部屋も同期に疲れたちょっと環境が変わったりし
てるんですけどもなぁ
11月後半もうすぐ
図形の季節ですねあえて受けてなんかやっぱりねそう勉強して大学で静岡に行ったんで
なんで zucca にくるとやっぱりちょっと勉強のことと数軒の事を思い出し
ちゃってなんか色々見てるとなんかいろんなものが出てきたんでちょっとそれを紹介
しようかと思いますぜひ
何かみんなの勉強のモチベーションになればいいなと思っているので今日はちょっと
ためになるいい動画になるかもしれませんとりあえずあの
まあ勉強ってもねー小学校
まあまあ
バカ中学校
馬鹿すぎて収入の英語のテストで確か13点取ってそこからちょっと宿に入りさせられ
ました
入りさせられたというか僕から入ったのかなちょっとヤバイということで久保の入れ
させてもらいました
でも本当に英語が全く出来なかったからな英語の勉強調査せられまくってそのまま強さ
まで勉強したら結構いい線いってそれはないが普通かな
ここに入ったんですえっとなんかこう言うねちょっと懐かしい味で懐かしいこういうで
雲のプリントをずっとやってたわけですよ
分詞構文えめっちゃコードやんふれあい enter the room 愛想
アナイス picture
全然三角とがついてますけど何が間違ってんだこれつ芸も分詞構文が何かも分からない
ワッハ全部忘れちゃった体感じでて kuma
のプリントめちゃくちゃやってたんだよたしかお水ねだけど参加が付いてます
チェッカーの結局ですね人はどこかで変わらないと目に進めないんでは彼だった僕は何
をすればいいかわかんなかったので何をすればいいかちゃんと書いてある苦悶の
プリントで勉強しまくったのがまぁちゃんと勉強というものに取り組んだスタートでし
たね
どこでプリントなんですけどほら分からない
何もにも色まで塗っちゃって飛んだ距離ならいけるんだよってまーちゃんと書いてあり
ますねわからない単語にはちゃんと塗って覚えようとしていたみたいですもうでも匹
だけ全然合ってないんですけどねまぁ人は間違って学習して覚えていく人間なのでこう
やって僕もまちがいまくりながら勉強してたわけですよくもんで
取れずよ人がいると取りづらいうやだ恥ずかしい
あ丸が付いた明日ありがとう併願でひたすら9ボンドというとやりまくってたら気づい
たらなんか英語が得意になってたよっていうお話ですもう一つ僕あの多分皆さん僕の
ドロミテできずいると思うんですけど僕日本語のとても下手で日本語がよく分からない
国語は苦手でしたね小説とか全然も意味を考えたってそんなの読む人によって捉え方
ってさまざまざと思ってたんですけどそうそう日本語チャット入れてねーなーとか覚え
てねーなって思ったんで簡単な文をもう本当にひたすらヤリまくりました
ベクトロスだいぶやってませ打ってるんで結構本当に混ぜて長やってるんじゃ俺
基本100点
それはそうだは中学校の問題でも中学ほど問題よ僕は高校の時に双剣をやりまくって
日本語の勉強をした訳ですよ国語の点数を上げるためにこういう道を得ますかみたいな
問題のときにほらもう少し長く
もう一個ももう少し長く全然長く日間家なんか居る英語が苦手輝きって国分が一番苦手
だったんだなっていうことにつきましたこれはもう
ちゃんとね行為って感じの練習とかも高校の時ですよたぶんこれ大この時に漢字練習と
しまくって中学校の
めちゃくちゃプリントをこなしまくる日々がまあ高校の初期になりましたなんでなんか
僕はの本当に多分ね私バカです僕はがですみたいな人いうと思うんですけどその人と
同じレベルぐらい分
いやもっとしたかもしれない結構バカな
んですよ今もたんですけどね
勉強にが出ない人って何したらいいかわかんないっていうのがいつもあると思うので
とりあえず僕学問で与えられたプリントをただただこなすというロボットに進化しまし
た
基礎的なものが何か着いてきたのかわからないんですけど大学受験に挑んだ時なんかね
勉強て頑張れば伸びるだろうと思うんですけど
まあそうもいかないときも彼はにありまして
どんだけ勉強してもやってない分野とかがあると絶対わからないじゃないですかその
問題が出たときのでちゃんと自分がどこの勉強をやってるかっていうのを分かりやすく
する
ように人生で初めてスケジュールというものを立てましたこれから多分これだこれこれ
これこれですこれですこれですねどっかでダウンロードしたのかな
ちょっと見てみますかあのうやなにこれ理科の解答用紙た
物理の物理の問題をした73点でした100点中
ママえないかゆはマジで懐かしいなこれ学習計画表というものを作っていました
使う教材とかを変えたり1か月の学習時間俺どんぐらいなるかとか過ぎ本試験まであと
何日かけるとこだったり午前と午後で何するかとか
一日の最後にできたかどうかとか11月だったら11月で何を勉強するかをすべて変え
ていま
明日島簡単に高午前午後夜って理由ってなにするかってねでこっちと見てみると7分で
書いてあるのは
何してたんだろうちょっとれざっくりすぎ国語だなさっきの苦悶のやつかもシーンで頭
の雲の国語のプリントをやってたんだと思います
日本語が下手すぎたんだよで55は英単語やって科学の1なんて時までやるかと書いて
へと物理6ページありますという夜はなんか漂っ車ますって言ってよ樂門行ったり行っ
て何するか数させたり
西南ベージュあるかあと10回これ10回目って誰の肝なんだけどねずっカイヤナイト
頭に入んないタイプだったんで
9月テーマはもうその日もあれば代々木ゼミの日もありますと推薦帰宅ハートって書い
てあるねてが1か月で135時間も勉強してなんだね
何時間勉強しましたっていうよりその日に何がに終わりましたみたいなちゃんと計画
立てて
試験の日まで全部できるかどうかっていうの計算だってやってましたねいつか外れたん
だろう
10月の11日だ10月の11日からつけずれたって勉強してたんだ
結構沿いのはこのちゃんとなりするか書いてあったよねこれマジでわかりやすいですよ
ね結局午前午後夜っていう卵しかないんで書いてあることをその後前に行っちゃって
午後に行っちゃって夜に行っちゃえば全部出来るんでバカな僕でもとてもわかり
やすかったですこれは cdb は寝るまでに30分嫁コレも多分でちゃんとやってた
気がしますそれもうすげーの前に勉強したら12月もやっ
てもうこれで1000ダース系までのこれ15日なんですよねまあ声センタープレスと
書いてある
ほら貯金2をしてたんだろうなぁだから校舎閉鎖1月矢部だけが懐かしくてちょっと
緊張するな
センター試験がありますね1日目物理の公式チェックと把握
なんかチェックして
すげえなこれしこれ直前の長センター試験の英語
やったんですけど
なんかねこれに100点中で確か192点取れたんでめっちゃテンション上がったん
ですけど当時て大失敗しました
加勢したね自分の力帆系掛け立てたいですよね
ね見通しないねそうですよね
同じ音と維持に年かっ
ありがとうございます
1ますけど順番者ができてたねしませんってきました
勉強のしすぎてぐらい本当僕もバカだったって
完全に天才は天才だけどねえ歳だけど勉強に関してはちょっとあのちょっとパワーが
なかったんでいうかまぁ努力というか消えてカバー c クリスがないかなと思ったん
でひたすら時間をかけてやってました工さんが人とはせん断試験近いと思うしあれやっ
ていいかわかんなかったんですけど僕は今見たとおり
何月くらやっぱり年10月の11か
いやもうマニアではごめんなさいマネはないですいやそこで諦めちゃだめなんですが僕
がちゃんと計算だって勉強したのが10円月からでそこから間に合わせてセンター式に
臨んだの出る5月から始めても僕は遅くないと思ってます静めるんだったらガムさらに
やるんじゃなくて計算立ててその日の午前2に何をするか
その日の午後に何をするかその日
の夜に何をするかを全部書きゃいい図を書けば書いてその通りにあれば必ずそれが実現
するんで僕計画立てたりするのが超嫌い大っ嫌いなんですけど
受験の時は計画立ててやって満足はいってないですけど結果はてたのかなって
ていますただただ勉強することも大事だと思うんですけど
料亭を立ててスケジュールを立てて後日にこなして言える目標に向かって頑張っていく
のがコツかなって思いますその頭良くないですけどばかなりの考えで頑張った月は勉強
でした
高3今すぐ焦る好きだと思うんで焦らず着実に勉強を頑張っていてください
めっちゃいいどうかさ
[音楽]
ん
me
バッハ